if you loved hamilton don't throw away
your shot to binge these five other
titles totally worth checking out
on this week's binge guide the cinematic
stage performance with the original cast
of hamilton is a certified fresh hit for
disney plus
and whether you like it for the great
songs stellar performances or its take
on history
these next five titles should be high on
your binge list
starting with our certified fresh pick
crazy ex-girlfriend
this musical comedy put out four
straight certified fresh
seasons and stars rachel bloom is a
woman who ditches her upscale manhattan
life to search for love
in california along with bloom's
performance and exceptional music from
the late adam schlesinger
critics praised this cw show for its
charming eccentric commentary on human
relationships
you can binge this series in just over
43 hours all while pondering why your
life isn't also filled with epic musical
numbers
for our throwback pick this week we're
headed all the way back to the late
1700s for hbo's john adams this
mini-series which actually came out in
2008
features emmy-winning performances from
juaro lenny and paul giamatti as abigail
and john adams
as it covers his role in this nation's
first 50 years
also taking home emmys in categories
like visual effects and cinematography
this show is praised by critics for
being elegantly shot and relatively
educational
and is a worthy addition to the genre
you can binge all seven episodes in
around eight hours which gives you
plenty of time to go read a few books
about the subject too
come on you slackers from history back
to musical comedy our audience picked
this week is zoe's extraordinary
playlist
the certified fresh first season has an
audience score of 88
and follows a girl named zoe who is left
with the ability to read people's minds
as they sing their thoughts
to go along with a strong supporting
cast that includes lauren graham and
skylar aston
critics say this nbc show manages to
carry a pretty enjoyable tune
thanks in large part to the always
charming jane levy
there's a second season on the way next
year but for now you can binge the first
in about 12 hours
and i dare you to try not to sing your
own songs while you're watching
our under the radar pick this week is
the amc drama turn
washington's spies with three of four
seasons coming in fresh the show is
based on the true wives of america's
earliest spies
an unlikely group who helped turn the
tide in america's fight for independence
mostly based on a popular book
washington spies critics say this show
delivers on the promise of espionage
thrills along with expanded historical
grandeur
and you can spy on history by binging
all four seasons in right around 30
hours of binge time
and finally our editor's pick this week
we're going with jesus christ superstar
live in concert this live tv event along
with three others we're recommending in
hairspray live
the wiz live and grease live are all
certified fresh
star power like john legend queen
latifah and julianne huff
are a big reason why these four shows
resonate with critics
along with blending those bold
performances with large scale production
pieces
originality and soulful depth you can
binge all of these in under eight hours
and after that you can
go back to listen to the hamilton
soundtrack on repeat
okay hopefully this will help you sing
your way through your next few binge
sessions be sure to let us know what
you're currently streaming in the
comments
and check back here for more
recommendations based on the
shows and movies you already love on the
rotten tomatoes
binge guy
you